[Musique]
ce serait un amuse gueule que vous
serviriez un plateau comme ça j'en ferai
mon il n'y a pas si longtemps si on
voulait offrir un plateau avec
différentes moutarde aromatisées il
aurait fallu à l'hiver des produits
importés mais voilà que des moutardes
artisanale bien de chez nous se sont
fait une place de choix sur les
tablettes des épiceries fines et dans
les marchés publics
pas étonnant puisque le canada est le
premier producteur de moutarde au monde
on commence à en voir de plus en plus en
effet simon aubertin du marché des
saveurs du marché jean-talon à montréal
est très au fait des produits en
boutique
on remarque beaucoup de moutarde
aromatisées
des saveurs boréale des petits fruits
ici sur la table on a deux catégories ce
sont des moutardes qui sont vendus ici
qui sont en partie ou québécoises ou
préparés au québec
tout ce qu'on a ici le cd moutarde qui
sont faites sans penser au québec donc
ici en fait la moutarde est vraiment
monté à partir du grain on part venant
de la base et tout est fait
exclusivement par la même personne
tandis que dans ce cas ci la moutade
d'être préparés ailleurs par reçoit un
petit artisan ou même parfois même dans
certains cas la moutarde importations et
aromatisé ici comme celle ci on voit que
c'est écrit moutarde de dijon donc
automatiquement si moutarde qui importe
et puis parfumé ici le prince charmant
donc un moteur de dijon c'est pas
nécessairement c'est pas une appellation
d'origine contrôlée donc c'est pas
nécessairement moutarde d'importation de
dijon mais c'est quoi une bonne moutarde
artisanale sa provoquant même une pointe
piquante en faux faux les cellules
essentielles sortir une belle acidité
avoir un petit côté vinaigrée évidemment
c'est à sainte marcelline dans
lanaudière que simon turcotte
confiturier et sa co propriétaire
geneviève sénécal ont tenté l'expérience
moutarde fait maison à 100%
on a fait des expériences et ses erreurs
évidemment mais le ça fait dix ans à peu
près là une fin d'année qu'on fait les
les moutons c'est quoi une bonne
moutarde
qu'est ce que ça doit avoir comme
qualité moi je trouve c'est beaucoup
l'équilibré des saveurs
ça c'est bien important
2 le dosage des ingrédients ça c'est
vraiment la clé faire une moutarde
demande du doigté mais la recette de
base alphonse et le trempage c'est
vraiment avec du vinaigre de l'eau et du
sine mais c'est la quantité de moutarde
blanche où brûlent con mais qui fait la
qualité du produit
le moteur brume et relever même piquante
tandis que la moutarde blanche appelée
aussi moutarde jaune est plus douce une
fois que ça à tremper pendant 18 heures
qu'est ce que vous faites là on est prêt
pour le broyage alors le les petits
bilingues est gorgé d'eau et des cidres
c'est quand on dit la moutarde me monte
au nez c'est vraiment dû associer qui se
passe quand le petit grain passe dans le
moulin puis que le petit grain de
moutarde éclater leur a fait une
réaction chimique qui fait que la
moutarde et les piquante et orge
alors une fois qu'elle est broyé on peut
pas la cuisine est tout de suite ce
serait beaucoup trop puissant
ça prend un temps de maturation alors là
faut laisser reposer pendant au moins
une semaine avant d'un rom attiser notre
mental dans une philosophie d'entreprise
les produits simon turcotte parfume
seulement avec des ingrédients de la
région alors là c'est là que je vois m
mes ingrédients comme l'érable emerich
beaumier ou le raifort ou à la fleur
d'ail c'est des ingrédients qui sont
très goûteux vu qu'une mousse liam ou
tard c'est quand même puis ça s'apprend
des ingrédients qui sont très
performants pour accoter le groupe ika
et arc he de la moutarde au marché des
saveurs simon nous fait goûter à des
accords moutarde saucisson et pâté de
lapin
mais le plus étonnant c'est le mariage
moutarde et fromages
j ai ren avec la victime la doré justice
une petite pièce de pâte molle on vient
juste mariam avec un tout petit peu de
mes tables de 10 joueurs comme ça
ceux-ci l'irrégulier et il ira bhl
lorsque ça va du découverte avant
probable une bonne moutarde bonnart et
en dernier lieu un petit accord avec
alfred le fermier cette moutarde à
l'ancienne au miel
on l'accompagné je fais partie des
québécoises comme la petite touche donc
on peut s'amuser à attester unis tablent
actuellement il n'y a pas de limites il
faut sortir des règles faux faux faux
tout essayé
[Musique]